herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute heute spiele ich mal wieder
eine app aus dem google places und zwar
vier bilder ein youtuber wer hätte das
gedacht das habt ihr vielleicht schon
mal bei luca gehört oder sehen auf dem
kanal und ich möchte mir jetzt auch
daran versuchen bei luca hat erzählt
gegen das übertrieben gut und er ist
komplett durchgerutscht ich habe eine
app gefunden die heißt genau so macht
das gleiche aber hoffentlich ein paar
andere youtuber ich habe mir extra nicht
lukas video angeschaut weil ich hätte
ich es ball abwehren wollte weil ich
wollte dass ihr alle schon weist und ja
daran versuche ich mich heute das ist ja
auch so ein bisschen wir dieses youtuber
starter packs ding was ich fordert
zweiten mal für mich selbst zumindest
ins leben gerufen hatte und darauf baut
es auf das so ähnlich und ja vertrügen
das machen wir jetzt ja da seht ihr die
app sie ist genau so aufgebaut wie der
handel und das ist jetzt wirklich
wirklich einfach also wer könnte das
schon sein natürlich ist es echt gar
wobei es gibt kaffee aus ägypten geben
aber es gibt kein deshalb probiere ich
einfach mal bluten aus vielleicht habe
ich damit mehr erfolg
und tatsächlich ersten youtuber ohne
probleme erwarten schauen wir wer der
zweite ist beziehungsweise die zweifel
wie es aussieht wir haben nämlich wir
haben schon ihre und schminkt kindle
anscheinend ist es also julia stegner
ist es natürlich weh die sbb und es
schon wieder richtig nächster youtube
ich könnte glaube ich nur von den farben
die jetzt so auf den bildern sind
erkennen wer es ist weil dieses braun
grün ist einfach hunger also
zweifelsohne weil die ist doch sogar ein
foto von ihm aber wie gesagt luca meinte
auf sei relativ einfach und wir sehen
natürlich auch erst auch level 3 am
anfang sind bestimmt die bekannten so
ich mal ein bisschen schneller das hier
ist natürlich jener nächster youtube
den kennen vielleicht nicht alle also
mimi ist das natürlich also als youtuber
selbst mimi ist das aber da hätten
vielleicht schon so die youtube nur so
ganz oberflächlich kennen vielleicht
schon ihre spielt keiner als youtuber
bis natürlich froh in dem spiel so als
nächstes das ist eindeutig german
display wie lange das einfach ist
[Musik]
ja optimal geschafft so ist das hier der
echte ein paar jesus ein fotoapparat und
noch ein foto von apo-med könnte ist
sich dabei um akkurat handeln
tatsächlich wer hätte das gedacht leute
das ist einfach ab obwohl zwei bonus
monat dabei sind ich hoffe mal das wird
noch ein bisschen schwieriger bratwurst
danke dafür
reilly und dönerbuden ali soll ich kenne
ich sogar gar nicht das ist glaube ich
auch so ein insider
machst du gerade ist das recht es ist
also ein
perfekt also bisher waren ja fast nur
jugend über mit über einer million
abonnenten da fürchterlich schwierigkeit
als nächstes ein fliesen tisch ein esel
ein bank mail ultra talent und reli und
rot pilz also einer der beide ist es ich
bin mir fast sicher dass das reh ist
aber ich habe ja schon fließend ich
gesagt ich wusste nicht das klingt das
so sagt hoch ist und das ist korrekt ist
es wie bisher kein fehler ich bin ich
sicher dass er das genauso gut gemacht
hat weil das sind alles total einfach
sachen vielleicht hat er irgendwie im
späteren spiel ein paar fehler gehabt
oder so mein ziel ist auf jeden fall
komplett durchzuziehen ohne einen
einzigen fehler ok waffe bad dreieck und
mütze das kann nur einer sein und zwar
mein guter freund war und wieder richtig
ok booster zahl rücke bademantel und
tanzverbot ich denke mal es ist
tanzverbot vielleicht liegt richtig
vielleicht auch nicht tanzverbot richte
wäsche lies der kfz und ein
dollarzeichen oder netlock hätte hat
miguel partner so führt burger kette war
schon verraten ich bin mit der ersten
single pablo und ich lege wieder richtig
und als nächstes wer könnte das denn
sein kollege ein alpaka pizza und ob dr
ich würde es ja gerne vorlesen
ich wüsste was es ist aber ich muss
leider sagen ich erkenne ich nicht genau
weil dieses alpaka so aussieht als würde
es ziemlich stinken nehmt einfach mal
kontra der korrekt ich habe schon wieder
geschafft unglaublich ah ok ich hätte es
mir denken können ist es halt ein
bisschen luft dass da immer ein foto vom
youtuber dabei ist weil wenn man ihn
kennt dann braucht man auch die anderen
nicht mehr
aber an diesem spandauer entferne ding
und wären mit blut hätte ich
wahrscheinlich auch erkannt das ist
kennt of blood ist und das ist wieder
korrekt so avocado nudeln und die helfen
mir nochmal pendelt das ist natürlich
ganz einfach und zwar ist das hier als
nächstes haben wir hier eine kleine
explosion okay ich weiß auch welche
explosion news und einen tunnel mit
augenringen
ganz einfach weil das ist also
explosionsgefahr das dvb t dvb busfahrer
arbeitet hat das müsste so fortfahren
und wieder geschafft ich sage einfach
mal song bay weil das unten rechts
aussieht dieser minecraft skin die
rechte figur und klar das monokel und
der gut ist sondern zwillinge tagte und
bruder verloren das sind natürlich die
lobbys weil es ein bisschen doof finde
dass man sie auf das wird auch sein
erkennungsmerkmal als nächstes pc games
pixel wolf und löscher das ist jetzt die
frage
pixelpark soll ich da pixel wolf oder
justin eingeben wenn justin ist jetzt
ein pixel holt es muss ja irgendwie
zurück liegen aber ich glaube es passt
nur justin hin justin und das ist
korrekt dass ist sie kein moment zur
hier
ich gebe es eine richtig gas und war
richtig das hier ist flash du dich
komplett aufschreiben weiß möchte
probiert man fresh tor geht das hier ist
barcelona gamer grip black ops bestimmt
wiska basar wie kommen
in dem fall nur wegen barcelona dorf und
heitkamm striking kombination wird es
hier ist patrick natürlich tritt
fortfahren
da steht doch ach nee machte das
bestimmt viel lautet würde sagen da
steht doch weiter die das ist sicherlich
bedeutet ich habe einfach nicht dazu
auch hier lustig will oder nicht so
nächste youtuber neutral subjektiv
benannte youtube sieht vor dass youtube
musik bewertet hat und ich wirklich
gerettet gerade das war mir nicht
beraten dass es höchstwahrscheinlich to
go ist to go ist es gehe hier das
korrekt weil sonst hätte ich ein problem
gehabt so melina melina melina auf drei
fotos vielleicht handelt es sich hierbei
um melina sowie das einzig schwierige
ist das halt der nachname auch dabei ist
aber ansonsten war das wirklich wirklich
einfach moment wenn dich das ist
überlegt gerade weil oben links bin ich
halt auf dem foto unten links sind aber
sebastian und luca nur das heißt nur
lukas auf beiden fotos aber konkreter
kann man gar nicht machen deshalb ist
das für dich wahrscheinlich krank der
leute ich wusste gar nicht dass ich in
mein handy spielerin bin voll cool das
hier ist keine frage der falsche ansatz
ich dachte man müsste den nachnamen
schreiben weil dann wäre ich absolut
verloren gewesen aber es ist anscheinend
einfach misses wieder was man schreiben
muss miss viele und schon wieder richtig
so kremlicka ist natürlich rein
das hier ist man tabletten und auch
wieder richtig dass hier ist erzählen
die als youtube wird natürlich ein kanal
der eltern dass hier
es wird höchstwahrscheinlich schon
design stimmt jolies film glaube ich
noch mit der leblicher machen
viele heute so di carlo sie das hier ist
das scorpion kommt dass pinocchio bildet
auch sehr schmeichelhaft auf jeden fall
marseille pompeo und wortwahl leute ich
hab ein problem fußball fitnessstudio
erster platz und das gesicht sagt mir
leider gar nichts
ich glaube ich muss jetzt tatsächlich
auf hinweis verwenden klicken buchstaben
streichen mache ich erstmal das hilft
mir kein bisschen
ich glaube ich muss nochmal buchstaben
freilegen machen free kickers als welt
dass die kritiker sind ich kenne
natürlich den kanal
aber manfred fickers das ich kenne das
wie gesagt ich kann natürlich den kanal
häuser und das dem fußball machen erster
platz wahrscheinlich in deutschland weil
sie die meisten abonnenten haben aber
dass die beiden jüngste an der seite die
friedlich das den bussen ich habe direkt
an fitness studio gedacht weil der unten
da in so ein schild das hier ist lion tv
okay hier haben wir es mit
und das hier ist natürlich teurer komme
mode hd richtig so fortfahren jay und
aria und auch spanier und aria fort fand
das hier ist krank aber deutlich würde
sagen es macht macht er toll doch gerade
aber ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt
langsamer schluss weil kein plan nicht
rasch durch ihr könnt ihr gerne mal die
kommentare schreiben war ich besser als
luca habe ich besser abgeschnitten als
er falls ja freue ich mich sehr darüber
falls nicht auch gut ich verlinke euch
noch mal das video von luca da könnt ihr
auch gerne vorbeischauen ansonsten wie
immer die frage wollt ihr mehr mobile
gaming das ist so ein bisschen das ziel
kampagne das herauszufinden ist normaler
abstimmung ein
und dann würde ich sagen bis zum
nächsten mal wir sehen uns